دائره امريكا الشماليه بالخارجيه الروسيه
اليكساندر دارت شيف حضر من التصادم
المباشر مع واشنطن كما اكد انه لن يكون
هناك اي تفاوض جدي بشان ضمانات الامنيه
فيم يتعلق باوكرانيا والمنطقه الاورو
اطلسيه
وذلك من دوني الاعتراف بالواقع الذي حددته
روسيا على الارض وقبل وقف ضخ الاسلحه
والمال لنظام جلاسكي وسحب عسكري ومدربي
امريكا
واشار دارت شيرفي لانه موسكو قامت قبل عام
بما سماها محاوله نزيهه للافاق ووضعتها
على الطاوله مشروعين اللي وثيقتين ملزمتين
قانونا بشان الضمانات الامنيه من طرف
الولايات المتحده
كما اعرب الدبلوماسيه الروسيه عن اماني
موسكو ان تصغي واشنطن لصوت العقل والا
تدفع بالامور نحو صدام المباشر الى ذلك
اتهم الولايات المتحده باطلاقها سماها
التدمير العلاقات الثنائيه موضحا ان مصر
كلها
بمبادره منها لكنها لن تتسامح مع
الاستفزازات المتعمده التي لا تتركوا لها
خيارا اخرا على حد يقوله